ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
hunters of all ages and monsters of all
stages DB Sinclair and J party here with
the Wraith and the third team of hunters
I'm excited J party to see what happens
here absolutely DB this is our newest
squad we just revealed as well as our
newest Mazda area we're gonna see some
cool abilities and some neat tricks
coming out of both sides of this game
here J party this is the Wraith and she
is a sneaky little assassin type
characters you're gonna see her using
some abilities called a decoy warp blast
supernova and abduction but before we
get to that let's see this team of
hunters coming in from the dropship
absolutely hearing doing their trademark
diving from the skies you will see if
they get in any spots on the monster and
look at that startled Birds right off
the bat here and that's a big win here
is that rain the dynamic weather we've
mentioned earlier it's gonna greatly
reduce a lot of the vision that they
have on this map so having an early
indicator of the monsters direction is a
huge win for the squad especially with
the rate that she has that decoy ability
which allows her to create a copy of
herself and then go invisible makes her
really hard to find you see the hunters
here using their abilities already to
try and track the monster and get her
locked down
you saw that acceleration field from
Kara this is now Abe using that tracking
dart pistol to track darts into the
wildlife which then if the Monster eats
them the monster will be tracked as well
great tool to mark an area and keep it
locked down once you've moved on and
left the zone to know if the monster has
gotten behind you somehow and look at
that they finally get eyes on the Wraith
you will see if they get an early catch
with this arena this can be such a big
win for the hunters if they can get a
stage war monster look at it and know it
doesn't go for the arena J party scene
that the Wraith is just on the cusp of
the range of the arena gonna put that
away and sees the Wraith coming back is
that the Ray J party or is that just the
decoy decoy it is hunters on the move
and I like what the trapper did they're
taking it slow keeping his patience
knowing that it might not be the real
Wraith and he's right it wasn't so
they're right back on the trailer of the
real monster but they need to catch up
boom he's just on the cusp of the mobile
arena zone good work by the trapper to
not waste that mobile arena
it does have a pretty big cooldown
you're seeing the Wraith using that
decoy ability to send the decoy out to
do her dirty work for her the decoy goes
out and will attack and do massive
damage to anything near it that's
wildlife or hunters the same and at the
same time the Wraith goes invisible neat
little trick jparty
absolutely a very cool ability with a
lot of functions both offensive and
defensive here but the hunter so close
now it looks like Cabot got eyes on the
monster just as she's going in a cocoon
and this could be a huge catch for the
hunters they definitely want to get on
the monster before she comes out of this
cocoon yes they can catch up to her as
it looks like they did they could do
damage as you see Cabot using that rail
cannon to do a little damage of his own
the team leader leading the team into
the firefight here does pop that cloak
though to get away from those wild trap
jaws and the monster coming out of that
cocoon with no armor this is a huge win
for the hunters they need to dish the
damage out while they can here a very
exposed monster oh but here comes that
supernova and this is gonna be a huge
damage the monster needs to try to take
down the trapper and bring that arena
down with them doing a great job of
chaining those abilities they're used
abduction to take the trapper away from
the rest of the group and then pop that
supernova to trying to damage the damage
dealer on the other side though is
Parnell Parnell using that super-soldier
ability to have extra damage of his own
and finally the medicating singled out
from the Wraith here as you see another
supernova attack and the medic could go
down at any moment and there she does
yeah good play by the monster singling
out the medic that's what you need to do
stay focused whoo whooping he did there
use that up using the decoy to distract
the team while he still can find another
character and goes for the pounce attack
nice sneak pounce rates not the only one
with invisibility as you know the
support class has that group ability to
cloak everybody around as he goes in for
the res on the medic looks like he's
gonna get her back up and he does but
the support down on just a bit of health
and not enough heals from the medic to
keep support in the game the Wraith
getting so low on this flight though
down below two bars of health and I like
this decision she's staying real passive
here knows the arena's coming down and
ferret goes this is her escape time she
needs get out of this fight regroup get
some more armor and then bring the fight
back at stage 3 clever move
sit on the edge of the arena and wait
till it was done and there she goes
that's gonna be another decoy nicely
done to send that back to the hunters as
she moves on forward hunters on the move
here with that acceleration field
working their way through the caverns
here hello no look out that's a
megamouth jparty megamouth taken the
trapper into his gullet before the team
finally gets there but that's a waste of
some serious abilities on the hunter
team yeah huge time sink they're getting
covered that megamouth that can be very
hard to spot as they look like just a
pile of rocks when they're not aggro'd
unfortunately for the hunters that's
kind of greatly slowed them in this
fight and they need to catch the rape of
course you can get to stage 3 still has
a long way to go on this journey I love
it jparty keep it a G rated for the kids
a pile of rocks
I've called the megamouth a pile of
other stuff before those nasty creatures
come out of nowhere absolutely can end
your game when you're not expecting it
as a hunter that's why you have to be so
aware of your surroundings and really
make note of the wildlife in your area
and that's what the Wraith is doing as
she moves through the map she's keeping
note of what's around here she's using
that decoy to help her take out some of
the wildlife so by the time she's killed
and eaten one tasty three meat there's a
tasty to meet waiting next door yeah
absolutely let's talk about the perks
we're looking at our hunter squad in the
top right section of your screen you see
that move speed perk on Kyra here and
that's a really effective ability for
the hunters it allows you to really keep
on the monster and keep him tracked here
looking back at our Wraith here in the
top right you see the ability cooldown
perk and that is absolutely one of my
favorites DV allowing you to fire those
moves off 50% quicker is such a huge win
in teamfights hunters on the move you
see and support there that's Cabot with
that cloak oh but he's not gonna be able
to hide from the plant the plan in fact
is not moving
how embarrassing Cabot to the plant on
the move there is Parnell trying to get
Cabot out and he does he's gonna need a
raise after that Jay below and at the
same time the monster hits stage three
such a brutal exchange for the hunters
that have to double back to get their
last squad member out of that plant and
now they're dealing with a final staged
up reef Wraith on the move let's see if
the trapper can find the Wraith and look
there she is jparty trying to get that
dart into her but she snatches the
trapper nicely
who's hunting who at this point J party
as the trapper is down to just a tiny
bit of Health and the trapper goes down
doing this best he can to stay alive
here until the rest of his team gets
there and they do thankfully he didn't
get knocked out of this fight completely
and hopefully Kyra can get him back in
as she does there meanwhile the trapper
did a great job of tracking with the
dart gun so the Wraith is visible to the
rest of the team that's gonna be crucial
in this fight here but the trapper being
focused again the Wraith trying to get
the trapper down to two strikes and the
trapper goes down all the support
they're trying to use that damage ant
weapon but with the rest of the team not
firing he's not getting a lot of utility
out of that ability as you mentioned
before jparty that ability cooldown
bonus on the raid so crucial right now
being able to switch between those
abilities back and forth running into
the fight and being able to pop that
supernova and do massive damage every
few seconds getting some really
efficient supernova damage they're
hitting at least two of the hunters at
once there that's not what you want you
cannot stay group here as the assault
getting very low on health learn early
low on health is the assault but Kyra's
in she has a lot of heals at her
disposal with that healing grenade
launcher and the healing burst but you
can see the Wraith again on the
supernova doing big-time damage trying
to take the medic down to two strikes
and the medic is down jparty
let's see if they can get her back up
and back in the fight that could be the
difference maker right now medic down
with a rate that one hit pony does that
have a lot of steam left in this fight
we're three hunters still up there just
laying on the damage but look at these
supernovas nearly endlessly with that
ability cooldown Oh
trapper tried to get the medic up like
the body was snatched with the abduction
back in with the decoy in the Wraith
wins